today's video is brought to you by athletic
greens supplement your health and nutrition
with their daily blend of vitamins and
minerals more on them in just a bit
she was described as the most
beautiful woman in hollywood's nay
the world she could enthrall audiences simply
with her gaze or by parting her lips just enough
to reveal the endless possibilities of sin her
life had all the markings of a modern day fairy
tale the story of a princess who made
her way through life thanks to her beauty
only to find herself locked in the castle of a
warlord a captivity from which she would escape
to conquer hollywood but nobody would suspect
that this austrian-born star had the brains of a
world-class inventor she was the screen siren who
inspired catwoman and disney snow white and who
invented the technology that would later enable
wifi and bluetooth today the story of hedy lamarr
the actress later known as hedy lamarr was born
hedwig kissler on the 9th of november 1914 in
vienna she was the only child of a mill and
gertrude trude kisler both parents were part of
the wealthy assimilated viennese jewish community
and were able to provide hedwig with the best
education trude introduced the young eddie to
classical music theater and the arts in general
she was enrolled in one of the best schools in the
austrian capital the doblinger middle school which
could boast anna freud daughter of sigmund as a
teacher however pre-teen heady had other concerns
beyond the liberal arts she had a knack for taking
things apart to understand how they worked and
reassembling them again afterwards a pastime which
delighted a mill who was supportive of her early
engineering endeavors but most of all hedy was
conscious of her beauty and how she would turn
heads wherever she went she also had an unruly
spirit that her parents did their best to keep
under control failing consistently for example
one of hedy's grandmothers died when she was 12.
as her parents were distracted by the funeral
arrangements the tween seized the moment to enter
a beauty contest which he won around the same time
the kisslers decided to lock the rebel girl in a
swiss boarding school as if that would work eddie
asked her friends to cable the school pretending
to be her dad demanding she return home the ruse
worked and eddie slipped back to vienna to attend
yet another pageant by her early teenage years
the young kissler was back in vienna igniting the
passion of older boys and dating for the first
time one of them was a 21 year old actor wolff
albacheretti later to become father of another
austrian star remy schneider this period is also
when hedwig took her first steps to stardom
first she signed up for acting classes then
got herself a job as a script clerk at sasha's
film studios austria's largest movie production
company she should have been at school but she
forged a note in her mother's name to leave class
and attend the interview while working there eddie
learned that a casting call was being held for the
minor role of a secretary so she stole some makeup
from another aspiring actress and gave herself
a bit of a glow up looking more stunning than
ever had he boldly told the assistant director
i want to play the part of the secretary and so it
was that she got her first bit role in gold on the
street released in 1930. the small part attracted
the attention of max reinhardt a director with
legendary credentials this wizard of theater
cast her in the stage comedy the weaker sex
with a part so small it didn't even have
a name the character was credited only
as first american but reinhardt uttered some magic
words to a group of reporters saying hedy kissler
is the most beautiful girl in the world the
quote was picked up by trade papers in october
of 1931 the spell had been cast and the future
star received more offers for cinematic work
hedwig moved to berlin where she shot two films in
rapid succession the trunks of mr of and we don't
need money hedy played similar characters in both
movies a sweet unglamorous young woman who is able
to defend herself with powerful slaps should the
need arise contemporary critics found her acting
just competent enough but obviously everybody
agreed on her magnetic beauty hedy had enjoyed
relative success in berlin but in february 1932
she decided to leave the city many fellow jewish
performers had taken the same decision sending
an imminent rise to power of the nazi party
and they moved to vienna one star however had
other motivations she had been hired by czech
director gustav mahati to act in the film that
would set europe ablaze with controversy ecstasy
photography for ecstasy began in july 1932 taking
place on the carpathian mountains had he played
the part of eva a young woman married to an
older man a mill who turns out to be impotent
eva leaves him and decides to reconnect with
nature by swimming nude and alike there she meets
the young engineer adam and the two fall in love
mahati's intention was to present the heroine as
a modern-day eve who reconnects with the garden of
eden where she meets her adam the main character
is presented as an independent young woman
who rejects the gilded cage built around her
by a decaying husband in doing so she becomes
a life-affirming force never ceding authority
to other male figures not even to adam along
the way mahathir and hedy earned a misleading
reputation for pornography there is in fact a nude
swimming sequence and a close-up of eva's face
during orgasm all tamed by today's standards but
not in the 1930s the star was initially fine with
those scenes but when x to see premiered in vienna
in february of 1933 she was dead embarrassed
nonetheless ecstasy was becoming a wild success
propelled by scandal and controversy on one hand
traditional conservative cinema-goers found
this tale of extra-marital sex disturbing
and disgusting on the other hand everybody else
found the nudity and the orgasm sequence to be
too tame the marketing campaign for the flick
promised all sorts of obscenity and not some kind
of art house film with just one shot of a naked
girl to them that was the scandal in any case all
this publicity could only serve hedy's goals she
was now the talk of european cinema and another
contract soon ensued in march of 1933 when she got
the lead role in a stage production about empress
[ __ ] an iconic figure of austrian culture
her performance was greeted with enthusiasm
by critics who for once praised her skills
instead of just her looks if this is the story
of a fairy tale we could say that this is when our
protagonist is recognized as princess of her realm
but this was also the moment in which the princess
met a dark and shadowy figure who would become her
captor fritz mandel now just before we get into
the rest of today's video quick word from athletic
greens today's video sponsor athletic greens
is a comprehensive all-in-ones greens powder
engineered to fill the nutritional gaps in your
diet and support your body's nutritional needs
across four pillars of health gut health immune
support energy and recovery it's packed with 75
right here vitamins and minerals and whole
food sourced ingredients combining the
perfect amounts of micronutrients
absorption and taste to jumpstart
your daily routine you would be hard pressed to
find a more comprehensive powder or supplement
on the market now let you guys know not exactly a
fitness youtuber you're not coming to my channel
for squat tips but i do like to eat
right take care of myself but i also
know there's gaps in my diet i don't get all
the vitamins but i do with athletic greens
you just put one scoop in the water bottle you
shake it up in the morning and you're all good for
the rest of the day plus it's gluten free dairy
free paleo vegan keto low allergy and low calorie
there's less than one gram of sugar per serving
one of the things i like about it it's kind of
gives me a sustained feeling of energy i have my
coffee in the morning i put down some athletic
greens green powder with it and i don't know if
it's placebo but i do feel better maybe i just
feel better about myself having something healthy
with the copious amount of coffee that i drink but
whatever athletic greens is the perfect dietary
support regimen so if that sounds like something
you've been looking for you can grab your own
immunity bundle that's a year of vitamin d plus
you get these five additional travel packs with
your first purchase at athleticgreens.com forward
slash biographics again year supply vitamin d buy
free travel packs at athletic greens.com forward
slash biographics or just click the link in the
description below and now back to today's video
fritz mandel came from a wealthy hungarian family
he had been born out of wedlock in february of
1900 from a jewish father and a catholic mother
the two married only when the boy was 10. an
ambitious man mandel made it big in the armament's
business earning the nicknames of austria's
munitions king and the merchant of death pritz
was also elegant charming and a smooth talker he
nagged mercilessly hedy and her parents until the
kistlers consented to an engagement announced in
may 1933. hedy converted to roman catholicism and
the two were married on the 10th of august 1933
soon embarking on a honeymoon across europe's most
luxurious destinations venice capri nice paris
all along the young bride had a taste of the
riches that this marriage could offer but she
soon realized that those solid gold bracelets
weighed more than handcuffs as she later put
it at every luxury except freedom in fact fritz
was blinded by a furious jealousy he demanded
that he quit acting and ensured that she did not
get access to the movie and staged celebrities it
was rumored that he ordered every print of ecstasy
to be bought and destroyed the rumor was probably
a publicity stunt concocted by the director
mcatee but it captures mandel's character well
after the honeymoon the munitions king locked up
his princess in his version of rapunzel's tower
villa fiegenberg about 160 kilometers outside of
vienna mandel demanded that hedy spend all her
time at home and not attend any social or business
events he even ensured that she was always short
on cash to better control her a battle of wit soon
ensued as the princess bride staged crazy antics
to escape pritz's control on one occasion she
removed all 16 toilet seats from the vast mansion
repainted them in bright colors and sat them out
to dry on the front lawn this was happening just
when fritz's business partners were arriving for
a meeting she then took to escaping from the villa
and going on wild shopping sprees buying on credit
of course when fritz saw the extent of the bill he
agreed to give her a fixed allowance one day after
escaping to vienna had he realized that fritz
was following her in her own version of events
she evaded capture by sneaking into a notorious
people show club but she entered the wrong door
and found herself on stage with the performers
having no other options eddie got into character
and improvised performance with a young male actor
it's often said that life imitates art in
this case hedy's life seemed to follow the
plot of ecstasy a young wife older husband and
extramarital passion one of the such flings was
inadvertently caused by a friend and client of
mandals a former italian journalist you might
have heard of this chap it's benito mussolini
mussolini was happy to buy weapons at a premium
rate from mandel he knew that fritz could use the
extra cash to fund count ernst von stehenberg one
of the top most austro-fascists and a leader
of the heimther militia ernst happened to have
a charming younger brother ferdinand who caught
hedy's eye and the two started an affair in the
meantime mandal was busy supporting the local
brand of fascism while he was opposed to an
annexation by german nazis mandel shared much of
their ideology including anti-semitism in fact in
1936 the austrian association of cinema producers
declared a ban on hiring jewish performers this
may have prompted eddie's plan to elope with
ferdinand on the 13th of november 1936 the
two hopped on a train to budapest where had he
planned to resume acting in theater but when the
train pulled into the station eddie was shocked
to see fritz waiting for her his face was a grey
mask of fury mrs mantle was promptly returned to
her gilded cage but it didn't take long for her
next prison break in early 1937 hedy hired a new
may laura her credentials she made for a credible
lookalike one morning the runaway bride slipped
three sleeping pills into laura's coffee after
she fell asleep eddie donned her uniform packed
a suitcase and snuck out from the servant store
driving laura's wreck of a car had he made it to
a nearby train station and hopped on a train to
freedom the experience with mandel had not been
entirely negative while she was supposed to play
the role of a trophy wife at business gatherings
she actually enjoyed discussing technical details
with mandel's colleagues especially engineers what
everybody had overlooked so far is that ms kessler
may have frequently skipped school but when
she was in class she excelled at science
her propensity for experimenting and inventing
would later pay off in a rather unexpected way
the mandel's marriage was dissolved years later
when hedy obtained a divorce in nevada after
leaving the states her first destination was
similar at switzerland a popular destination
amongst jewish showbiz personalities seeking
refuge from germany and austria while there
the princess on the run had a brief affair with
eric maria remark also a persona non grata due
to his novel all quiet on the western front but
the two soon parted ways and mrs kusla reached
london in the summer of 1937. this is where she
was introduced the man who would open the gates
of hollywood for her co-founder of mgm louis b
mayer the film tycoon was interested including
her in his new batch of imported european talent
he was also aware of the fame that she gathered
thanks to ecstasy and was quick to admonish her he
said never get away with that stuff in hollywood
never a woman's is for her husband not
theatergoers mayer also picked a new name
for his new acquisition kisler sounded too german
and mandel had political connotations from now on
she would be known as hedy lamarr after the late
silent film star barbara lemar on october 4th 1937
the reborn miss lamar signed her first contract
with mgm with a weekly salary of 550 about 10
000 in today's money despite plenty of attention
from the gossip columns hedy still struggled to
find a suitable role she spoke little english and
some camera tests convinced mgm directors that
she really could not act that was until producer
walter wagner had an insight with her dark hair
wide eyes and foreign accent lamar was an
embodiment of exotic beauty perfect casting
for exotic dramas and so she got to star
in 1938's algiers are all coveted by
ingrid bergman in this drama set in algiers casbah
lamar plays the role of a passionate woman torn
between an older husband and her young lover a
gangster what a surprise a review of the time
read best of all is the smoldering velvet voiced
wanton mouthed femme fatale blackhead hazel-eyed
viennese actress hedy lamarr suddenly our heroine
had broken into the fantasies of millions of
american cinema goers her looks even inspired
the character design of sydney's snow white
initially drawn to be blonde later she would also
inspire the first version of catwoman the success
of algiers was followed by lady of the tropics in
1939. in this romance set in saigon hedy plays a
multi-racial woman born to a french father and
an indochinese mother and guess what she's torn
between an older powerful industrialist lover
and a younger suitor surprise another pattern
that emerges is that mgm was typecasting
heady into stereotypical roles the trend
was confirmed by 1942 with white cargo here the
austrian beauty plays another exotic seductress
the half egyptian half arabic ton de laio these
films did do well enough at the box office but
lamar would later regret not sinking her perfectly
aligned teeth into meatier roles for example in
1940 she had turned down the classic thriller
gaslight even worse in 1942 she had to decline
the part of ilsa in casablanca for contractual
reasons the role went to ingrid bergman of course
during her early tinseltown years hedy lamarr
married and soon divorced two hollywood
personalities first the producer jean markey with
whom she adopted her son james then she married
actor john loda with whom she had two children
denise and anthony all the while she maintained
a hobby only a few friends such as howard hughes
were aware of designing inventions hughes gifted
her portable engineering equipment so that she
could invent away in her trailer between takes
had he repaid the favor by streamlining the
tycoon's racing airplane lamar also invented
a tablet that could turn a glass of water into
a cola drink she also invented an anti-aircraft
shell with a proximity fuse after the u.s entered
world war ii in december 1941 she wanted to do
more for the war effort together with a friend
composer george anthel she developed an idea
building on frequency hopping a concept originally
patented by nikola tesla in 1903. lamar reasoned
that naval torpedoes were given input for both
depth speed and direction but were left unguided
after launch how about developing a technology to
control their trajectory remotely hedy went one
step further how could one prevent the enemy from
jamming those directions given via radio signals
with the help of anthiol an expert in mechanical
pianos she devised a contraption similar to
a piano role that would switch between ata
frequencies very hard for the enemy to intercept
this method was patented on august 11th 1942 under
the name secret communication system the invention
was fully developed by the u.s military in 1959
as a device to control early drone models three
years later during the cuban missile crisis all
u.s navy vessels to enforce a blockade on cuba
were equipped with the technology and jumping
even further ahead the lamar anthill secret
communication system became a fundamental
component of wireless communication systems
including wi-fi and bluetooth this invention alone
was estimated to be worth at least 30 billion
dollars in today's money and yet hedy and george
never saw a single cent the sad truth is that the
navy rejected the invention back in 1942 they
understood its theoretical advantages but found
it to be too cumbersome to put into practice
and in later years lamar failed to renew the
patent application during the war years the armed
forces believed that eddie lamar could serve her
country of adoption in another way she bolstered
the morale of gi joes by joining uso events and
more importantly led a fundraising effort which
sold 25 million worth of war bonds in just 10 days
with her contract with mgm expired she invested
heavily in producing her own movies the noir the
strange woman of 1946 was a moderate success but
dishonored lady one year later was savaged by
censorship and tanked at the box office this did
not help eddie's finances as she was known for
reckless shopping sprees the 1940s though closed
with hedy's biggest success to date the biblical
epic samson and delilah directed by cecil b
demille and starring victor mature as the male
lead commenting on mature's pictorials groucho
marx famously quipped first picture i've seen in
which the male lead has bigger than the female
as much as we love groucho barks and his humor
we expect that lamar wished to be remembered for
something more than a figure but such was the life
of a hollywood star and one on the decline too
at the age of 35 movie offers started to dry
up after working with demille had he only appeared
in six more films the last being the female animal
in 1958 hedy's declining years were accompanied by
trouble and heartache at home throughout the 1950s
and 1960s eddie got married and then divorced
three more times the wild spending the box
office bombs and the divorce lawyer bills left the
once glamorous star financially ruined in 1965 she
confessed to a fan i have no idea where my next
meal is coming from and some days i go hungry in
1966 she had the chance to return to the screen
with the horror picture mummy dead but she first
failed to show up on set and when she did she
collapsed due to exhaustion in february she was
fired from the production the year 1966 was the
start of a series of curious appearances in court
earlier that january she'd been arrested for
shoplifting however the judge found her innocent
and released her in the following years
she appeared in court again and again
this time as the plaintiff first she sued
the ghostwriters who had penned her 1966
autobiography ecstasy and me and accused them of
inventing scandalous details and lurid stories
then in 1974 she dragged to court comedy legend
mel brooks guilty of naming a character hedly
lamarr in his blazing saddles apparently brooks
was amused by the attention and agreed to settle
out of court next up were the newspapers san
francisco chronicle and the national enquirer
the chronicle the dead publishing the photo of a
two-headed goat called hedy lamar while the latter
claimed that the once star had become a pathetic
recluse old and ugly by the 1990s hedy was living
in a small flat in miami supporting herself with
a social security check and a screen actors guild
pension she was arrested again for shoplifting in
1991 and this time she was sentenced to a year of
probation in april 1998 eddie found the energy to
file her final lawsuit against software company
coral corp her photo had been used without
permission on the cover of coral draw
hedwig kissler better known as hedy lamarr died on
the 19th of january 2000 in castlebury florida up
to the end she kept coming up with new inventions
a fluorescent dog collar a type of new traffic
light and even improvements for the concorde in
her last years eddie had become obsessed with
plastic surgery some say she was attempting to
recreate her long gone beauty true hedy owed her
success and film career to her looks but deep
inside she despised them in her autobiography
she wrote my face has been by misfortune it has
attracted all the wrong people into my boudoir
and brought me tragedy and heartache for five
decades my face is a mask i cannot remove
i must always live with it i curse it perhaps
that's what she wanted to do through surgery
punish and erase the face that had distracted the
world from her true talents a gift for innovation
invention and inexhaustible lust for life she
once said when i die i want on my gravestone
thank you very much for a colorful life the
actual quote in our gravestone represents much
better heady's world view and achievements films
have a certain place in a certain time period
technology is forever i hope you found
today's video interesting if you did please do
hit that like button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching